because i lost my family back before i'm
so hurt i'm so depressed even i try to
kill myself someone eating situation in
myself
that's why i don't want to happen with
me like
inside like when i don't want to lose
her because i love her my
ex-husband is coming to visit me where
this house
okay well we're also gonna meet your
ex-husband leandro
you say that you two are just friends
but he's coming to ethiopia to visit you
do you see why binyam and his sisters
have a concern i mean i see why binham
is concerned if he wasn't concerned at
all it would be weird right but
i mean he should be concerned his sister
should you know i don't know if that's
really
you know to say
it's not necessary a little bit it's not
their business you know because it is my
my friendship it is my past and my
present you know a lot of people i tell
vinnie like a lot of people don't
get along with their exes
and
i get along great with my ex that should
be like a positive thing like a white
flag not a red flag benim did you ever
think about just telling ari no he can't
come
or did you want to see
this man in person
yeah i wish i would i feel i would tell
him like
i don't i don't want because of my it
was because of my culture
like for me like when they called in my
culture like it was weird like something
it was very hard for me like that
situation how would you feel ari if the
roles were reversed
in his well hey actually i can answer
this question very well because grenion
was dancing with his ex-dance partner
with his ex-girlfriends and dance
partner playing buff bongos and
everything and what did i do i just i
smile i said well great job so
i think it's time that vineyard
experience a little bit of the same
that is a great point that totally
slipped my mind and mind you while we're
on it binyum what was up with that were
you thinking in that moment like hey my
woman is watching me with my ex and i'm
sitting here playing drums on my ex's
butt
me and my ex-girlfriend like we didn't
we didn't go like for too much like
for a relationship that at least you
have a very relationship with the
headsets once
that's why i'm so jealous because i have
communication if he closed too much i
don't want it to start again and then i
don't want to lose by my and again my
family because i lost my family back
before i don't want to lose again that's
why i'm so wealthy why do you think you
keep running into that same scenario but
you haven't ran into it again i guess
you're just afraid to uh you meet an
american girl
right and then
[Music]
are you afraid of this you're afraid of
the same thing happening again because
when i let the first my relationship
when i i lost i'm so hurt i'm so
depressed
even i try to kill myself so many things
situation in myself that's why i don't
want to happen with me like
inside like when i don't want to lose
her because i love her she's giving me
baby like something i don't wanna lose
ourselves like this wow um but i wanna
say though that this season is gonna be
definitely entertaining partially
because my ex-husband landr is a really
a character
yeah i can't wait to meet him i'm
curious so if you don't mind sharing ari
what happened because you guys were
married for 10 years right
so what was it that made you realize
okay we're better off as friends
well it's kind of a weird situation like
what happened with me and my ex-husband
because
we don't have like any animosity towards
each other
uh i think we got married when we were
really young i was 19 years old so
it was like
uh at that time i didn't even know what
it really meant to get married i just
knew like oh you know i want to be with
my best friend forever i don't want us
to be separated so let's get married
and
uh i think we as we like
grew older we realized like there's so
many things we didn't experience in life
and like if we stay you know maybe
staying together as the husband and wife
is not really
the best thing for us but i think we
kind of explored a little bit in the
season like
me and land or get a chance to kind of
talk about it
and i get a chance to kind of hear his
perspective because i didn't really know
like at the time i learned some things
even i'm sure i'll learn more things
watching the season wow
and i'm just i mean just hearing it it
does it didn't it doesn't open up any
old
feelings like i just think that's so
mature what you're doing is so mature
well you know like i always say i know
i'm not perfect and you know no one is
perfect so
i'm sure i made a ton of mistakes in my
past relationship and yeah it definitely
doesn't open up like when you see
someone they haven't seen it in a while
and you're in a new relationship it kind
of does open up like some thoughts like
oh like
it i it kind of made me realize and
focus like on some of
possibly the traits that i have that i
should work on you know seeing him again
and then
it also made me feel bad because um
i i started wondering maybe
you know maybe even though it's all over
are there still unresolved feelings
maybe
on his part so we talk about i think a
lot of that stuff for this season
well benny after meeting leandro how do
you feel about him i mean do you see why
he and ari are such good friends
has it made you trust her more how do
you feel about him
i don't know very hard for trust him
because
especially for me like
even i say that because they especially
they talking like spanish
like for long time the spanish
that's
for me is very hard like you know
what is i don't i don't know what is it
talking about because it's not my
language that's why it's just more he
makes me like more jealous yeah yeah
okay
well we saw that a moment where neither
of you were talking but you were
fighting
you binium and leandro
what was okay what can you tease about
that i want to be like tough and then
just i want to show him like like a man
i'm a man come on talk to me like that's
what i want to write
i'm sure he would understand though ari
does he understand binyam's position
yeah i think he definitely would you
know the funny thing is when i was with
lander like i never felt like he was
jealous of anything that i did and i
always wondered like why is he not
jealous of me now i'm with vinnie and
i'm always like why is he not jealous
and just now i'm understanding
you are so jealous
oh
we know that i think this season like
something is going to be hilarious like
there are some moments like
cross-cultural moments and so you're
like oh my god is this really happening
and then there unfortunately there's
also well or fortunately depending for
the viewer there's also really some
really emotional moments um you know my
son obviously
my son he
gets sick and i have to take care of
that and then you know me and binyam
really had to make a decision what was
the best thing for avi to do
and then me and bingham we had a lot of
really difficult moments uh this season
and you know it's really
um
i think it's going to be really
difficult for the both of us to relive
it and to rewatch it so yeah on one hand
is going to be like there's going to be
some really funny things i can't wait to
see them and on the other hand i don't
know how much i'm looking forward to
reliving some of our more sad homes